so as we pick up with a third part of
our House of M event what we're going to
find here is that things are going to
move at a very very fast pace what we do
is we start this story is that we pick
up with Wolverine and what's really
interesting here is again we really tack
on to the fact that everybody's gotten
their hearts desires and this reality
when it's revealed to us that Wolverine
remembers everything he does remember
bits and pieces of his whole life he
remembers his whole life and what this
tells us here is that these memories
that Wolverine had were not gone and
tire than like he believed they had not
been wiped from his mind they had simply
just been suppressed over years and
years of having his mind tampered with
which is really interesting because
again what this does is it tells us how
much power the Scarlet Witch has where
Charles Xavier has spent years trying to
restore the memories of magneto The
Scarlet Witch was able to do it in a
single action or perhaps Charles Xavier
didn't want to restore all the memories
he only wanted to restore part of them
we're not exactly sure here but what we
do is we follow Wolverine as he begins
to succumb to everything that's going on
and he jumps from the Helicarrier in
order to escape the questions from
mystique as well as this presumed I
guess lifestyle that he's been leading
so far and what happens as Wolverine is
almost immediately pursued by mystique
as well as Jessica drew and toad and the
rest of his shield team and so what
happens is that while Wolverines trying
to escape in the streets below he's
found by Luke Cage now initially it's
cloak that actually picks him up and
takes him back but Luke ated been the
one that was tracking him then when
Wolverine arrives in front of Luke Cage
what Luke Cage says is that Wolverine
needs to disable the tracker in his neck
Luke Cage says that he knows that
Wolverine is part of a Sebastian Shaw's
red guard The Wolverine as part of
shield and the shield wouldn't know we
inevitably be looking for him and so
what happens is that what Wolverine is
overwhelmed here he fails to follow the
instructions of Luke Cage and Hawkeye
appears then it tells us that Hawkeye is
alive in this reality indicating that of
course the scholar which had brought him
back to life and so what takes place is
that over the course of the next few
minutes Wolverine is basically knocked
unconscious by a by Hawkeye and what
happens when Wolverines comes to is he
asked them how long he was out
and when they say he was out for about
30 30 seconds or so Wolverine tells them
it's too late and the entire group is
attacked by by shield sentinels and so
what happens is a cloak uses his ability
to teleport to immediately move them
away and takes them to the mansion of
the kingpin and so this is when the
questions begin to start rolling in we
of course see questions on both sides
the first question will rain asks of
Luke Cage is why it is location rescued
him and of course Luke Cage is asking
him questions like why it is a Wolverine
knows who he is and so again as they're
continuing to go back and forth
eventually Wolverine is the first one to
acquiesce and Wolverine says that it's
not going to make any sense to Luke Cage
but Wolverine was a new Avenger about
two days ago and then he suddenly woke
up and found this circumstance and
everything being what it was and things
had changed drastically and he says this
is not the way the reality is supposed
to be the things are entirely different
now the initial response of Wolverine
expects from Luke Cage is that Luke age
would be in disbelief but what Luke Cage
says is that a girl named Layla Miller
had come to him a couple days beforehand
and its whole Luke Cage the exact same
thing that things weren't right that
something was wrong here and so what the
group does is they look up Emma Frost on
the throne book due to the fact that a
Wolverine says that Emma Frost was
formerly a leader of the x-men before
this reality had taken place and that
Emma Frost will know what to do and so
what they do is they arrive at the
apartment of Emma Frost and when she
walks in her initial reaction is a
skepticism she actually freezes
everybody in place but then we see that
Layla Miller basically awakens her and
this is the process whereby Layla Miller
wakes up or I guess reactivates the
memories they have of the real life of
the real world and Emma Frost we get
over is I guess overcome with with grief
and anger here but her initial response
is the same as Wolverines in the sense
that the idea here seems to be that
magneto is the one responsible for all
of this and so what Emma Frost says is
they basically need to go about and
awake as many superheroes as they
possibly can so that they can band
together and they can confront magneto
and so what happens here is they take it
in turn to confront various people they
confront Doctor Strange they confront
Tony Stark they confront a Peter Parker
spider-man as well as a litany of other
individuals and ultimately they come
together in a single location to make
the decision on what it is it needs to
happen here
and again the group recognizes the
difficulty in this situation the sense
that because magneto is basically the
leader of the world here because he runs
everything he's going to have an
exorbitant amount of security to say
nothing of the powers that he has here
and so their best bet is to somehow find
a way to to attack magneto using some
kind of a secretive method to basically
distract him and so what we do here is
we switch to Magneto and what we find
out is that in this particular instance
Charles Xavier appears to be dead here
now Charles Xavier is a really
interesting and nygma in the house of
him because what we're going to find is
that the events as they've unfolded that
is to say this new reality could not
have been done without the mind of
Charles Xavier and we're going to find
just how far deep that goes but what we
do is we pick up with with Magneto as
well as various other individuals as
they're going about and having some sort
of grand celebration gala and what this
does is it again continues to show us
all these other people who are part of
this reality the name of the Submariner
is still part of this reality the Victor
Von Doom is again the leader of Latveria
as well as the head of the Fantastic
Four in this reality we find that that
storm is the queen of Kenya and again
what this tells us here is storm like
Colossus had never been removed from her
environment at the hands of Charles
Xavier because Charles Xavier apparently
didn't exist here and so as a result she
simply maintained her current life no we
don't know if she's still some measure
of a thief because remember during the
original x-men series during the a
giant-size x-men story we had seen that
she had been basically liberated from
her lifestyle by Charles Xavier as being
a thief in order for her to join the
join the x-men and so again as things
progressed as things continue we
ultimately see that the plan of the I
guess the awakened superheroes begins to
come to fruition when the group as a
whole sends a sentinel skyrocketing or I
guess plummeting towards the grand
celebration gala at the house of Magnus
and of course magneto being able to
control a medal is easily able to
sustain or I guess to uh to shut down
the signal and to keep it from crashing
into everything in destroying and
possibly killing people but what we do
is we realize that during this entire
instance that again this was the
distraction that the awakened
superheroes were used
and amidst the chaos and amidst the I
guess the distracted various people here
that ultimately the group immediately
descends on to the house of Magnus and
begins attacking various people with
that being said we're going to go ahead
and bring this video to an end I know it
was very very short but bear with me for
that and that will catch you guys later
peace be sure to follow me on Twitter
there you can keep up with all the
updates from comics explained and talk
to me directly